i love seeing the enthusiasm for machine
learning among
our customers it is a testament to the
technology's potential
to change businesses and industries for
the better
machine learning is one of the most
disruptive technologies we will
encounter in our generation
more than 100 000 customers use aws for
machine learning today
right from creating a more personalized
customer experience
to developing personalized
pharmaceuticals
these tools are no longer a niche
investment our customers are applying
machine learning to the core of their
business
now let's take a look at some examples
domino's pizza uses machine learning for
predictive ordering
to help meet its goal of delivering hot
fresh pizzas
in 10 minutes or less following an order
roche
the second largest pharmaceutical
company in the world uses amazon sage
maker to accelerate the delivery of
treatments
and tailor medical experiences cabbage
an american express company applied ml
to their loan application process
and surpass major u.s banks to become
the second largest business payment
protection program lender
in the country preserving an estimated
945 000
jobs across the u.s the bmw
group is using amazon sage maker to
process
analyze and enrich more than seven
petabytes of data
in order to forecast the demand of both
model mix and
individual equipment on a worldwide
scale
using amazon sagemaker nike built a
product recommender
on nike.net to deliver a more relevant
shopping experience
to its wholesale customers and finally
in sports
formula one applies machine learning to
their car design process
giving them new insights into more than
550 million data points
collected through more than five
thousand single and multi-car
simulations
as you can see our customers are
innovating virtually in
every industry so why do our customers
choose us
they choose us because of our depth and
breadth of services
and the rapid pace of innovation so now
let's take a look at
our machine learning offerings
at the bottom layer of the machine
learning stack we provide
ml capabilities for expert machine
learning practitioners
these include optimized versions of the
most popular deep learning frameworks
including pytorch mxnet and tensorflow
and we provide choice in infrastructure
across gpus
cpus and our own silicon innovation in
training and inference
as well at the middle layer of the stack
we have amazon sage maker which allows
developers
and data scientists to build train and
deploy
machine learning models at scale
sagemaker
includes a broad set of capabilities
many of which
are both novel and unique to aws
and these services are available through
an integrated development environment
for machine learning which we call
sagemaker studio
many organizations are standardizing on
sagemaker
to remove the complexity from each step
of the
ml development workflow so that it's
faster
more cost effective and easier to do
at the top layer are our ai services
where we are helping customers adopt
machine learning without having to build
their own models from scratch
in vision we have recognition and in
speech
we provide text-to-speech with poly and
speech to text with transcribe
and customers can create their own chat
parts with amazon likes
for text we provide natural language
processing with comprehend
translate for translation and text rank
to extract structured text from
documents and images
we have also applied amazon's more than
20 years of experience in machine
learning to deliver services
including amazon personalized for
personalized recommendation
amazon forecasts to automatically create
custom demand forecasts and amazon fraud
detector to identify online fraud we
have also built
end-to-end solutions including contact
lens for amazon connect
for contact center analytics amazon
kendra for enterprise search
amazon code guru for automated code
review and devops guru to improve
application availability and last week
we introduced services that are custom
built for industrial sector
as you can see we are innovating really
fast and at a rapid clip
to meet the needs of our customers